بعدما كان امبراطور العملات المشفره
وعبقري الاسواق الماليه الجديده بين ليله
وضحاها تحطم كل هذا على شواطئ المهاماس
سامو البنك والفرايد البالغ من العمر 30
عاما اصبح منبوزا بعدما واجهت شركته ازمه
السيوله وتقدمت بطلب لاعلان الافلاس ما
يعني منعوا حصول ما لا يقل عن مليون شخص
من المذيعين على اموالهم
السقوط المدوي من النعمه الى الافلاس اذهل
المستثمرين وعشاق العملات المشفره الذين
اشد ذات مره بالامريكي باعتباره المنقذه
لهذه الصناعه ولكن ما الذي حصل حقيقه
ليدفع بالرئيس التنفيذي السابق لشركه اف
تي اكس للعملات المشفره المنهار ان
يتوجهها للعالم عبر تويتر ليقول اعتذر
لانني اخطر فقط
في الثاني من نوفمبر الماضي استشهد ما
قالوا استقصائي بوثيقه ماليه مسربه اثر
التساؤلات حول التعاملات اف تي اكس
والمخاطر العاليه التي تتخذها
اسس النظام البيئي باكمله
وتراجعت اسعار العملات الرقميه جميعها حيث
دفع المستثمرون للخروج من المراكز
المحفوفه بالمخاطر ونتيجه لذلك وفي حاله
من الزرار زرع المذيعون لسحب اموالهم من
العديد من منصات التشفير مما اجبر
المقردين على وقف عمليات السحب
الفارس الابيض لقطاع العملات المشفره
انتهى به الامر معتقلا وصناعه العملات
المشفره على حافه الهاويه في انتظار سقوط
قطاع الدومينو التاليه بعد فتره وجيزه من
انهيار افتكس انخفضت قيمه المزيد من
العملات المشفره السائده مما في ذلك
البيتكوين والاسيريوم والصلانه
شاب غامض يبلغ من العمر 30 عاما تمكن من
شقي طريقه عبر دوائر يهيمن عليها المشاهير
والمشرعون والمستثمرون الاثرياء
ظهر على اغلفه
تم ترحيبه به على انه لن وفاه العملات
المشفره راكما سوا شخصيه هائله بلغت حوالي
26 مليون دولار في ذروتها في وقت سابقا
هذا العام ولكنه اليوم موقوف وانتظاري
محاكمه وصفت بالتاريخيه في الاوساط
الامريكيه السياسيه والماليه على حد سواء
لصباح
ريتا سليمان واشنطن